primo a ricominciare con il gameplay di
oggi volevo solo farvi vedere una roba
alla veloce questo è il testo per andare
sulle opzioni e se io click opzioni c'è
questo sono qua
e già così mi sembra di essere tra le
braccia di satana prove sono tutti
ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video sono
fa vj e oggi siamo su sophis la
maledizione di soffi creato da lui
scontrare se ti voglio mai incontrare su
zio che ti pigli e botte solo letto la
guida questa qui che lampeggia che non
ve la faccio leggere per l'amor di dio
quindi ho capito più o meno come giocare
la faccia modalità corso siamo partiti
ragazzi allora sono le sette di notte re
sacca tua il controls ok no non aspetta
però e fammi vedere cazzo non ho letto
in tavola l'obiettivo ragazzi è quello
di guardarsi in giro e tentare di
sopravvivere a questa sofica è una bella
donna ma come si clicca a regà a col
destro che ci sono questi cosi che devo
ricaricare ma non c'è ma che l'e3 è
questo a a questa regola è che cazzo ne
so io descrivete melo ci sono questi
cose devo ricaricare a mano con la
manovella nel mentre circola lì che mi
dovrebbe dare fastidio che non la vedo
assolutamente questo cos'è il b ok però
io cristiano come sono come faccio a
sapere che quale la quale il b e qual è
il chip ad ora culo bella sta stanza
tutto buio tav è bellissimo perché tu
non fai niente di frames me e cazzuto
cioè nel senso ti muovi pure questa cosa
qua e stranissima ok ok tutti i prefetti
che non voleva così quella roba a terra
la società batte gillet
ci mancavano pure i tuoni ragazzi
fantastico sono ancora capito chi sono
io però va bene ragazzi non importa è
sta qua perfetto se ne sono fregati
era un check point grazie a dio con le
otto di sera ma come le otto di sera io
fino a che ora devo far st vita di merda
spiega mino perché il genere i giochi
non mi piace posso fare continua grazie
sul tasto continui così mi fa continuare
dalle 8 invece che le 7 grazie cara ai
partiti dalle 8 quindi quando sono morto
adesso sta porta dovrebbe non lo fa più
mi hai preso per il culo prima po
stronza perché ha fatto prima a sbattere
la porta e poi è spuntata qua è già
meglio di find and the hill freddy's
perché almeno i check point sono di ora
in ora
grazie a dio che mi segna già di quella
[ __ ] che ha bruttissimo
ma mai preso con il fatto così da una
vita ma mica quante la brutta regala una
brutta brutta questa era dal non so
quanto che non abbiamo un infarto del
genere acqua eccolo qua questo è un
computer in teoria dovrei aprirlo non so
come cam motta come sia preso così ecco
henry e robert orr you there ciao e
rimandano tranquillo è vero sofia
veramente in casa amico come vorrei
essere lì ma sei scemo scemo a ok check
point sarebbero le nozze all'orario in
cui arriva ecco quindi prossimo seguente
alle 2 di notte hanno alle 10 alle 10
scritto qualche est i grand carsi cosa
che quello che torino si può quindi save
point e prima del della stanza da letto
qua io sto qua a [ __ ] è il 6 point è
quello dove sono adesso se io sto qui
non mi prende allora uno mi dice la
perché cazzo non stai fermo lì finché
non arriva alle 10 perché se si spengono
questi cosi celano il culo lo stesso
anche save point ben chiuso il discorso
che cosa c'è ed ha attaccato che consuma
così tanto ma che è il vibratore
come fanno a scaricarsi così tanto è
impossibile effetto
veloce perfetto l'effetto sul veloce su
salvo sono salvo
casaro manca quanto manca ancora niente
un'ora ma anche un'ora e un quarto porta
minopoli minuti vanno avanti alla cazzo
di cane il teoria dovrebbe ogni minuto
dovrebbe essere un secondo ma invece no
perché ogni tanto vanno avanti come gli
pare a loro quindi va bè scendi scendi
scendi veloce non dovrei farlo e perchè
c'era la tipa però se non solo veloce
veloce skin brutto [ __ ] perché non
sfruttare ti prego iddio ti prego iddio
60 a gesù interrogate ansia come non c'è
niente che faccia a faccia a faccia una
certa cifra c'è miliardi e via via via
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via via via via via veloce 6 poi
se poi sei poi mi chiedesse ricercato
tutto ok avevo letto nelle soluzioni di
gioco che quando succede sta cosa che
lampeggi devi andare al 6 point in
quanto si scaricano veloci adesso cosa
che ho appena fatto quindi giusto il
problema è che si sono scaricati tutti
subito manca mezz'ora ce la faccio
mezz'ora ce la faccio mezz'ora ce la
faccio veloce
non che ogni volta che nel giro di
qualche sembra che debba saltare in
bocca non so perché lo stesso sono
ammessi solo sono solo non si può
installare 6 poi sono sull grazie gesù e
roero sopra 6 point e ringraziando iddio
mancano 9 minuti veloce io mi sto qua io
sto qua devo arrivare alle 10 prima che
si scarichino i cosi veloce ma quando
cazzo mi è venuto in mente di giocasta
roba sono vivo non so come non so come
sia possibile errore sul di ferro a
svegliate anzi se è successo non sa cosa
non mi ricordo cosa devo fare con galan
sia chiamata un elettricista era andato
in errore o devo fare
save point al coin devo cosa devo
cliccare con dove c'è
calmi ex sono essi poi sono esseri fa in
calmati ok farà mori partito cosa è
successo cosa dove quando va in errore
cosa devo fare le che hanno capito chi
me lo fa fare di andare qua minchia lo
sto corridoio l'odio e che può uscir min
al momento all'altro e poi ragazzi non
ho capito ma quando mi spunta come
faccio io scappavo io mi sono girato
prima nel corridoio e messa al data in
bocca in teoria pensavo che si vedesse
prima invece no ti salta proprio addosso
la [ __ ] che c'è un gatto in casa non
è proprio il momento adatto per
occuparsi di un gatto te lo dico è che
quando sento sono morti i sei volte giu
e giù per oggi sono lontanissimo lo
salva tornando anche per il cazzo sono
salvo manco fuga
mancava ma poco un passo ma neanche un
po un laccio di scarpe ed era arrivato a
6 point ma neanche quello anzi a sta
cosa che per andare avanti di cliccare è
sempre qua la polizia ha detto che
impari che i genitori di soffi sono
andati fuori con gli amici alle 7 è stig
ragazzi perché ci sono stato io questa
bambina de merda non ho capito quindi io
sono un baby sitter
quindi io do fasti baby sitter che
accende le luci su un gatto
ma perché ogni tanto un gatto io non so
scemo sento solo io con te brutto sto
gioco l'odio bruttissimo veramente
preferisco giada phinet freddi se che
mario insieme a praga e facciamo
l'ultimo tentativo perché non ho capito
è che ai raduni che faccio incontro un
sacco di gente che mi dice minchia ho
giocato al nuovo phinet extremis come
che non lo provi ma mi chiama che
problemi c'hai per giocare a sti giochi
spiega non ce li ho già capiscono una
minchia di mio
questo punteggio e jewels e toni cosa
vuoi che faccia brutta [ __ ] vai in
autostrada ultimo tentativo e me ne vado
basta lo scassato il pene vabbè cliccare
sullo schermo non so perchè ma mi mette
ansia
ok fate i giochi col joystick l'ultima è
poi basta veramente l'ultima poi basta
ne voglio più sapere
poteva non mi fai scendere le scale ti
odio basta mi sono rotto il cazzo
ragazzi basta
guarda come viene dal cuore dire basta
perché gioco mi divertiva non mi
dispiace lasciare così episodio che
morisse il cavallo diarrea acuta tra
questo veramente tragico ma ma tragico
proprio cioè orribile vi giuro e è
peggio ma veramente peggio di fi un ente
stradis peggio
niente ragazzi se avete alcuni consigli
visto che molti di voi sanno come
giocasse cose non mi spiego come spiega
terminati come si gioca stack agata e
cercherò di fare meglio se riesco per
l'amor di dio spero che viene siamo 100
ragazzi con la senti subito piaciuta
documento è un mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook e con i video transizione
sono riti discreti amici mi chiamano
prossimo c'è la ragazzi